[Music]
today's question comes from jessa in
michigan i am a loan officer at a credit
union and i absolutely love my job but i
also am on the day of ramsey plan and
have i have fell in love with teaching
your concept to our members about
getting out of debt i feel like a
hypocrite because basically my job
involves me creating debt do you have
any advice for us who are stuck in
corporate america i feel like i am not
part of the solution to money issues but
have become part of the problem what
fields can i pursue so i can become a
solution
well it sounds to me like jessa really
enjoys the financial industry yeah and
so she's she's obviously because she
believes in what we teach at ramsey
solution there is a conflict there now
first we start with jessa
you aren't part of the problem you
aren't a bad person you are not doing
anything that's unethical uh or illegal
however i understand that the values
disconnect so if you love finances
the planning the strategy the numbers
and all that kind of stuff and you want
to help people win financially that
doesn't involve debt i'm looking at
one of our smart investor pros you know
you know our system i really want you to
reach out to somebody uh in our in your
area that's a smart investor pro and go
hey ken coleman i was the ramsey show
they read my thing and told me to call
you guys i think about moving into your
side of things because i want to help
people win with money not get weighed
down with money and i think coffee lunch
a phone call
to learn a little bit more about the
investment side of things financial
planning certainly financial coaching is
an option
working for an organization that
has good products and services that
better people's lives and maybe you work
in the finance side of that company what
i'm trying to say here is there's a
whole lot of opportunities for you you
don't have to feel as though you are
painted in the credit union corner you
can do a lot of what you like to do in a
lot of different places and she's saying
she's a loan officer and she loves her
job and if you do that i mean we have
our friends at churchill mortgage
they're helping people get mortgages the
right way that's right so i think it's a
great opportunity if you work for you
maybe you are a mortgage loan officer
you help people understand the right way
to get into a house that isn't going to
bury them and so you go hey i want you
to do this there's a great way to do
this here's the kind of down payment
here's what kind of mortgage loan i
would steer you to and here's why to
where she can actually help people
that's right do it the ramsey way and do
it uh financially that's a very good
point george she may be able to stay in
the credit union if it's a perspective
change don't
push somebody to a bad product but if
you're getting pressure to push to a bad
product then if she's making car loans
all day i get it yeah but if you want if
you love the loan industry i think
mortgages might be something that she
could get into where she could really
help people and really guide people to
do it the right way really good stuff
there